- Welcome everyone to your
coffee break with me here,
Heinrich on Firm Learning,
the channel where I want to
help you become successful
in the first years of your career.
And one from you,
someone from the audience
sent me a slide deck
of one of the largest companies
in the world of Amazon.
And it is a slide deck that was presented
in one of their quarterly conference calls
where they present the
latest financial figures
often to a set of analysts
and other important stakeholders
to give them an update of
how the company is going.
The reason I want to
discuss this with you today
is because frankly,
this is one of the worst
slide sets of this importance
that I have ever seen created
by any of these large companies.
I think this is quite remarkable.
So I want to discuss with you first
what makes these slides so bad?
And second I want to
discuss what you could do
to improve them if at
any point in your career
you would be in the position
to create slides like this as well.
So let's start by having a first look
at the slides before
we go into the details.
So here, the cover slide of
this already looks quite basic,
to say the least.
The next one seems to be
some type of legal slide,
of course, very text heavy
but okay for a legal slide.
I guess that's fine.
And then these are the typical slides
that you see here in the deck.
And I hope that you agree
without even going into the details here.
Just the first look and
feel is just very bad.
It looks like an absolute
amateur would have created this.
Every intern who just
spent a couple of months
in professional services I would claim
would be able to create superior
slides compared to this.
And now, before we look
into the slides on detail
let me first stress one point
which might actually be
the most important point.
So what do you want to accomplish
in such a financial earnings call
where there are all these analysts,
all these investors to whom you talk to
and you share with them
the financial numbers.
And this is exactly what's happened here.
So just slide after slide,
they're just sharing some random numbers.
What would an investor likely think
if the investor sees a slide like this?
So the free cash for
the available cash flow
seems to go significantly
down over the last year or so,
but there's no statement, no explanation,
no rational about this at all.
The only comment is that
there's a long term goal
to optimize free cash flow.
What does this mean?
How is this giving any
confidence to investors at all?
There's anyone at this company working
who has some type of plan
what needs to be done?
What was even driving this decline
in free cashflow for instance?
So all of these obvious questions
are not answered at all.
This is more or less just a data dump.
It lacks any narrative.
It lacks any storyline.
If you want to learn more
about what you can do
to actually improve this for your slides,
I created lots of videos
on this in the past.
Probably the entry point
for this specific topic
would be the videos on
action titles that I created.
I will link it somewhere
above here for your reference,
but now let's go a bit
more into the detail.
It's really the composition
of these slides.
And let's just started
with the very first slide.
And of course, many of the
things that I discuss here
on this slide are relevant to
all the other slides as well.
And let's just first talk
about the aspect ratio of this.
So this is a slide with
an aspect ratio of 4 to 3.
And this is just so incredibly outdated.
Even when I started in
consulting in McKinsey in 2013,
I believe it was,
almost no one was using
this 4 to 3 format anymore.
Today, almost every slide that you create
are done in a 16 to 9 aspect ratio
where it gives you the benefit
that you have far more space on the slide.
And it also gives you the benefit
that now there aren't
black bars to the left
and to the right.
So this alone just
completely outdated, really.
So also surprising they're doing it.
Then second, let's look at this.
One of the things that just
makes the slide look busy,
not really clean and nice,
is just all the different font sizes
that have been utilized here.
So notice here how this long term goal,
this is bigger that here,
the Q3 axis are smaller,
but then the axis on the
Y axis are bigger again,
then here, the numbers are
the same as on the Y axis.
Also some other things, for instance,
these two dashes here, just
looked very unprofessional.
Why would you do that?
What exactly is the meaning of this?
Now let's look also at the chart itself.
So first of all there's one principle
that I want you to have in mind,
and this is the principle
of the data-to-ink ratio.
So just very basic principle
is that you always want to
show as much data as possible
with as little ink as possible.
Ink referring to any lines that
you are drawing on the page.
Just a common thing that is
just not necessary at all.
Especially if you have
bar charts like this.
Just to have this additional Y axis.
Why do you need this Y axis?
Just take it out
because then of course
you have the numbers
on top of the bars.
This is at least what I
would recommend you to do
to have numbers on top of the bars
because for whatever reason,
these ladies and gentlemen
at Amazon decided
that they just include a
number on the very first bar
and the very last bar.
Why is this the case?
So what if someone would want
to know what here in Q2, 2021,
the trading 12 months average was?
Is the person supposed to take out a ruler
and somewhat try to
understand based on the axis
what number here for Q2 is the right one?
In addition to this idea
of data-to-ink ratio,
why is there this weird
light blue background here
in this chart?
What value is this adding?
What is this saying?
This just wastes ink,
especially if you print out such a page.
On a black and white printer,
depending on the contrast
setting of the printer,
you might not be even
able to just separate
the bar from the background anymore
because the background is colored as well.
So just absolutely no need for doing that.
Don't just randomly use
background colors like this
if it's not needed.
Let's also just look at another
inconsistency of this page.
So let's look at negative numbers.
Let's first look here at the axis.
So we see that this axis
goes down to -40,000,
actually here with this legend,
- 40 million US dollar, I guess,
but here now this is denoted as a million,
whereas here the negative number
is denoted with these two brackets
which is another way of
denoting a negative number,
which is a fine way.
You can do that, though I would
say not the most intuitive.
I think not everyone understands this,
but if you do then at
least do it consistently
throughout the chart.
Why would you use the one in
notation and the one inside
and then the other annotation
at the other hand side?
Just another smaller thing
that I also talked about in some videos
is the use of this dollar sign.
That's always a bit of a problem.
Maybe you could argue the way for Amazon.
It's clear that this is US dollar
but let's at least acknowledge
that there's so many dollars on the world.
There are Canadian
dollars, Australian dollar,
Singapore dollar, Taiwanese
dollar and so on and so forth.
And at least as far as I know,
all of them use this dollar sign.
So don't use this dollar sign
to just denote the currency
but rather use the three
letter acronym, right?
So USD for US dollar, for instance,
if you would want to talk about dollars.
Next let's talk about alignment.
So the basic idea is
when you arrange elements on such a page,
that there should be as
few just logical levels,
logical areas on the plane
of the slide as possible.
And just to start here at the left,
usually you think about design spaces
where the slide starts at
a given point to the left
and ends at a given point to the right.
And this is maybe a minor comment,
but for sure,
if you would work at a firm
like McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
I mean you will get feedback
on things like that, right?
So this bar here, the long term goals,
this border around it,
this starts to the left,
but actually the axis of the chart
starts further to the right of this.
So it's not really aligned to
the left border of the page.
And there's no apparent
hierarchical argument,
hierarchical reason why
that would be the case.
Next let's look here at the
legend on top, the MM on top.
So this is neither center
to the $80,000 unit that is shown here
nor is it left aligned to this unit.
So just somewhere randomly
placed here on the chart.
Let's also look here to the
right side of this chart
where you see that also here
the chart doesn't end nicely
aligned to the right border
of this border around the
long term goal text box.
Let's look here at the footnote
that also just seems to placed
here completely randomly.
It is neither aligned to the border here
of the long term goals box.
It is also not aligned
to here, the dollar sign.
So it starts further to the
right than this dollar sign.
So just looks completely random.
And then last but not least,
let's also talk about
this turquoise box here
that says down 171% year on
year, I guess this means,
which is also just randomly
placed here, right?
So it's not nicely centered.
You would expect this to be centered.
It's also brief.
You talk about the messaging of the page.
We also briefly touched upon it
in the beginning of the video.
So first of all,
I would always recommend to you,
I think this is what the
professional standard is
to use the so-called
action titles on slides.
So not just writing free cash flow
but using an action title,
but then even if we
read this takeaway box,
as you could call it here at the bottom.
It says Long-Term Goal
Optimize Free Cash Flows.
Again, what does this mean?
How do you know?
So first of all, what
is the long term goal?
Second of all, how do they
optimize free cash flow?
If I look at this,
they're not optimizing free
cash flow at all, right?
Free cash flow seems to
be going down like crazy.
So if they have a goal in
the future, what is the goal?
And what are the tangible measures
that they wanna put forward?
How can any analyst trust
that they will succeed to
do that based on this slide?
I think that's a very big problem.
Next, a slide like this,
where we talk about net sales.
Again, just notice how
this is just a data dump.
Just some numbers.
Again, the most important
numbers are even missing here
because it's not really
appearing on the bars.
But let's all notice that this
turquoise bubble here on top,
so here it says up 7% year on year,
but then also up 9% F/X adjusted.
So F/X is the foreign exchange rates.
But now if I look at the numbers,
are these now the adjusted numbers,
so the F/X adjusted numbers
or are these the non F/X adjusted numbers?
And now there even a footnote.
Now I'm reading the footnote
but I'm not really getting
this from the footnote.
Of course, I cannot start doing the math,
start calculating whether 116 over 108
rather corresponds to 7% or to 9%.
To some I get to it,
but of course, this is
just very unprofessional.
The numbers not labeled correctly.
Just leave so many questions
when looking at this.
Now let's look at a slide like this.
So I think of course,
many things I already commented on
are apparent here as well.
Of course here the use of
pie charts in the right
is also problematic.
So I also created a video
about data visualization
in the past that I will
also link it above here,
where talk about why the use of pie charts
is in most cases unprofessional.
I think you're seeing many
of the problems here as well.
But now ask yourself also,
how is this pie chart related
here to the chart on the left?
How exactly does this go together?
And now I trust if you
maybe now pause the video
and think about it,
after some time you will understand
that the sum of these three
figures makes up the 477 million
or 478 million here in the end,
but that's not really intuitive
at all how this is shown,
especially given that
for instance this orange,
so this AWS yellow orange
type is more or less the same
as this yellow orange color
here in the bar charts, right?
So you could assume
that maybe the bars here
are actually AWS, which is, I mean,
more or less exactly what
this legend is applying.
But of course, this is not what's the case
because this year on
the left is the total.
Whereas here the three are
components of the total.
So if you look at all the other slides,
more and more problems
like this are apparent.
I hope you agree how these
little things really matter.
Really add up to an
impression of such a document,
which is just incredibly unprofessionally.
I would of course be very interested
in your perspective as well.
Do you agree with this judgment?
Do you see it differently?
Let me know about your
views in the comments.
Very interested to hear about that.
By the way if you want to step
up your slide writing game
I'm partnering with think-cell,
a PowerPoint plugin,
that is used by almost all
of the big consulting firms
to create charts.
I have a special offer that are negotiated
with think-cell for you
with an extended free trial
and single licenses.
You can check it out in
the video description.
If you took any value
from this video at all
hit the like button for
the YouTube algorithm.
Subscribe and turn on
the notification bell.
My name is Heinrich,
where you see weekly videos
here on this channel.
See again next week.
All the best to you and bye-bye.